There are six stages or
modes of a design sprint.
And each of these stages solves
an important part of the design process.
The first phase is the understand phase.
In this phase, you're trying to
get clarity on the business goals,
the problem you're solving for,
technical feasibility, the market, and
user needs.
You've actually already been working on
some of this throughout the first two
lessons of the course.
And there are other activities that
you can do, which I'll cover later.
The second stage is the define stage.
In this stage, you might define the goal
for the product or certain features.
This might include the positioning,
a user journey, or
metrics related to the product or
those certain features.
We'll cover more about
metrics in lesson 4.
Now, this stage is similar to what
Richard Fulcher was talking about when
he mentioned tasks that
are related to a user's goals.
For example, a user may search for
a particular grocery item
in our shopping app, which would be
then added to the cart for purchase.
The third stage is the diverge stage.
In this stage, you want to create
as many solutions as you can
to the original design challenge.
And this is the stage where you really
get to unleash your creativity.
It's the fun part.
The fourth stage is the decide stage,
and in this stage,
you really just want to deliberate
about the ideas that you came up with
in the previous diverge stage, refine
those, and then choose the best one or
some combination of the ideas so that
way you get a best possible product.
The fifth stage is
the prototyping stage.
In this stage, you want to actually
create and build the wireframes,
the mockups, or the prototypes that
you'll actually test with real users.
These are the deliverables
of the design sprint.
And finally,
the last stage is the validation stage.
In this stage, you really want to
test your products with real users.
You're testing your wireframes,
your mockups, or your prototypes, to
determine whether or not the hypotheses,
or your risky assumptions are true.
You're trying to figure out whether or
not you have the right product, and
whether or not it's usable.
So there you have it,
the six stages of a design sprint.
Understand, define, diverge,
decide, prototype, and validate.
Throughout this lesson, Amir will
interview a design sprint master
at Google and
talk more about each of these stages.
I'll follow those videos by
describing activities that you can do
with each of these stages.
As you watch the videos, think about
which activities might be helpful for
your specific design challenge.